[Music]
how's it going bros my name is we
actually need to hurry [__] up here hey
it's not there anymore cool oh yeah oh
yeah I remember I remember we're back
here in the freed moners and last
episode we got a freaking shotgun
actually God damn this shotgun is it
looks good but it's actually horrible
and I just killed myself while I was
talking anyway uh this is pretty much a
let's play and a nutshell I let's play
I'm doing a
Le me dying pretty much a million times
I'm
here
uh and I can't get down there without
dying someone gave me a tip but I don't
remember what it was I think it was
something about jelly beans
but I think I need to figure out what
I'm going to do actually I mean God damn
it maybe I'm not supposed to go there
maybe I'm supposed to go click that
thing
yes why did I go there God damn it all
right I got it I got I got this it's no
problem it's no problem now we have a
problem ow okay where's the thing I
click where the [__] did it
go okay here it
is and that turns red for whatever
reason and then I go here and that turns
red
too what What chop chop chop chop chop
all right we're good new area yeah I
live ow ow it's you it's dogs
I holy [__] ah they're [__]
everywhere Jesus penis all right we're
just going to [__] I'm so
screwed ow ow ow ow that's not a very
friendly new area all
right die [__] die thank you holy
[__]
okay die [__] oh they explode right oh
God damn it s more okay it's shotgun
time I'm going to [__] you dogs up come
here dog
ow I'm not ammo all right this will not
end Chop Chop ah God damn it how the
[__] am I going to do this all right
quick save I don't know why I do it
quick okay it's good it's it's cool ow
ow Jesus Christ you're
annoying Jesus Christ I suck okay maybe
I can escape somewhere okay girls ow
let's go okay that didn't work let's try
I told you I would die I told you I
would die a million times it's good it's
good
okay I pressed the [__] bottom I
don't know what the [__] I did oh I
opened
there holy [__] you're sexy as [__] he's
like Kiss Me Baby Kiss come on I dropped
my [__] on your what is that looks
disgusting all
right okay boom all why it work first
time I need to be more
conservative ow this is [__]
difficult holy crappy crap wait wait
wait I got to mess message from someone
saying like skill
one no no you know what we should do we
should actually go back here and that I
didn't really find a way to do it so I
guess my my best bet is
to kill these little [__] okay I have
three God damn it I'm so
screwed I don't really understand how
the [__] they work but I'm I'm
running there really are things to kill
you everywhere in this game all right I
get it I get it do you don't like me
quite frankly I don't like you very much
either I don't get what triggers the
[__] okay Dodge the Sperma guy Dodge
the Sperma guy it's cool all right holy
[__] I'm no don't you dare follow me
don't you close the door please all
right let's do a quick sa apparently you
can find [__] in
there yeah yes 20 holy crap all right
chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop I want a soda please
please please
please is that a door hello let's go in
here hello Shar what are you doing here
hello Petty I've been waiting
shotgun Health give me my drugs I need
my drugs give it to me yes more [__] to
click I
guess a door open I get it's from the
garage I would hope let's reload the
shotgun oh you dog's going to get stuff
now come on come on dogs you think
you're tough
huh they are
tough oh I'm here okay [__] screw you
guys go they're coming okay okay it's
this way later dogs see like a dog ah
more
dogs
I holy
[__] that scared me
again don't you that scare me that's
what you get that's what you
get okay more
dogs ow
[__] okay let's it's a Sperma guy again
where the [__] did that thing come from
I think the gun is honestly better than
the
shotgun yes it is
okay okay reload
reload got to get that boom boom boom
all right we're good there that little
[__] I hate you why would you scare me
like that all right I only have a
shotgun now it's good it's good we need
to loot some [__]
let's loot some [__] [__] loot ah I hate
when they crawl holy [__] that's creepy
all
right okay we got no problems here I had
bigger problems okay F6 apparently save
with I got a message
from Ruma the guy who made the game uh
that was a bro tip thank you bro um
anyway those doesn't look very friendly
like hey py how you doing
hey it's been a while py hey how you
doing
I ah Jesus
Christ okay let's Chop Chop let's Chop
Chop this last one chop chop chop CH
chop CH ah God damn
it so difficult I mean it's a freaking
shotgun this you'd expect the spread to
be better but let's see if we can try
find some [__] is that [__] no I guess
it's [__] technically but not the kind
of [__] that I would like not that I
necessarily would like [__] I don't know
what I'm talking about the lock is and
I'm out of battery too so that's
fantastic all
right I killed Reuben first you're
Reuben
what didn't get Reuben okay okay
Reuben's down it's like no you kill
Reuben my best buddy I don't care you're
ugly
F you kill my buddy ow I'll kill you I
don't care [__] all right it's Manu
[__] Mano buddy you speak Japanese
you speak Japanese chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop huh you speak my language
huh it's Mano [__] Mano here all
right fight to the [__] death all
right come here Bry come here bro come
here bro you scared bro huh you think
you're tough huh you think you're tough
[__] tough huh I kill you buddy I
kill your best friend huh I feed on your
anger ah ah run face why would you do
that Jesus CH no he's got freaking
backup holy [__] I'm out of here Ruben's
got freaking backup Jesus Christ that
guy has his connection and [__] godd
damn Reuben all right yes new area I'm
awesome ah this game is so difficult so
I mean every time I progress I'm like
yeah I don't know what all right I I
don't actually do that yeah that kind of
seem [__] hey oh God damn it flying
demons now holy [__] they're sending the
whole [__] freaking chivalry at me ah
right here too I need ammo or anything
Jesus
penis I don't even
have
[__] all right we're good holy [__]
my best buddies in the world boxes chop
chop chop chop chop CH chop CH chop CH
chop CH chop chop chop ch ch ch ch yes
yes thank you painting actually you're a
door I can't thank you can I close doors
I want to close door after to me all
right yes [__] yeah all right all right
come on buddy come on bro come on bro
you think you're top
huh all right it's only
one [__] I you stole my ammo all
right okay we're good I actually got
them hello
okay we're good
we oh [__] okay it's Chop Chop Time come
on where where tell me [__] where
okay come on bro I didn't mean to kill
Reuben okay come at bro come at bro come
at me
bro stupid son of a [__] stupid son of
a [__] the door is damn chop ch ch ch
ch ch ch chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop Chop Chop Chop
Chop Chop Chop God damn it I can't chop
them a I'm sorry I didn't mean holy [__]
holy
[__] okay what am I doing what am I
doing what am I
doing what am I doing I need to kill him
I think can I go here yes yes F6
[__] all right I need to see
how long 11 minutes all right I promise
i' do a little longer so
let's nope I'm not doing
longer anyway uh subscribe to become a
bro today like and favorite if you
haven't already and I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
by there's a save kitty cat right there
what is this something is
glowing I would be more concerned about
these a student maybe they can tell no
no no no no girl girl I'm not
responsible for what she's about they I
knew it mother of pit